ارقام مذهله وتوزيع غريب كشفت عنه منظمه
اوكسام غير الحكوميه وذلك مع افتتاح
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في تابوس وهو
اكبر تجمع لاثرياء العالم الرقم الاول
مذهل وهو ان واحدا في المئه فقط من البشر
يملكون ثلثي ثروات العالم الجديده والتي
بلغت 42 تريليون دولار هذا الرقم هو ضعف
الاموال التي كسبها سبعه مليارات شخص ايت
الساعه 99% من الشخص من سكان العالم
المنظمه تقول ان الثروات الطائله تزاملت
مع فقر متوقع في ان معا لاول مره منذ 25
عاما اما بالنسبه للتوقعاتها تشير اوكس
فامي لانه بعد عامين فقط سيكون هذا العقد
الافضل بالنسبه لاصحاب المليارات ايضا
المزيد من التفاصيل والارقام في الشرح
الثاني
شهيد اصحاب غير عدي لثرواتهم خلال سنوات
الجائحه والازمات الاقتصاديه العالميه منذ
20 20 استحوذ اغنى واحد بالمئه من البشر
على 26 لترليون دولار اي 63% من جميع
الثروات الجديده بينما ذهب 16
وهي 37% فقط الى باقي سكان العالم كل
ملياردير حصل على ما يقرب 1.7 مليون دولار
مقابل كل دولار من الثوره العالميه
الجديده التي يكسبها من البشر الفقراء
يظهر التقرير ان 95 شركه غذاء بطاقات
ارتفعت ارباحها باكثر من الضعف في عام
2022 ودفعت منها
257 مليار دولار الى المساهمين الاغنيه
مثلا اسره سام مولتون التي تملك نصف شركه
8.5 مليار دولار خلال العام الماضي وشاهد
الملياردير الهندي جوتام اذاني صاحب شركه
طاقه كبرى ارتفاعا بثروته بنسبه 46%
بمقدار 42 مليار دولار في عام 2022 وحده
[موسيقى]
كل حال المنظمه غير الحكوميه اقصى بعد كل
هذه الارقام اللي عرضناها وعرضتها قدمت
ثلاث توصيات اولا ضريبه تسمى ضريبه تضامن
وهي تفرض لمره واحده ثانيا زياده الضرائب
على الاثرياء والثالثا فر ضريبه على
الثروه اي القطاع منها وطبعا كلها
اقتراحات مثيره للجدل ويعتبرها كثيرون غير
واقعيه وربما على كل لانه يناقش كل ذلك من
سيدني ينضم الينا رجل اعمال في راس بدر في
راس السادس صباحك اهلا بك في الوقت الذي
يشهد فيه العالم ارتفاع في مستويات الفقر
المدفع 26 عام نشاهد ارتفاع في ثروات رجال
الاعمال وفروات الاغذيه كيف يمكن تفسير
ذلك كثيراس اقتصاديا
صباح النور يعني بالبدايه بتمنى نقدر نجرب
نفصل عمليه
نفصل التصنيف الاثرياء من ثراء مشروع
غير مشروع يعني
ما فيكي تيجي
نحط كل الاثرياء بسله واحده والعقم على
اساسا
اذا بنرجع السبب ال ال الفقر اللي عم
بيصير
80% من مسببات الفقر هي نتيجه الحروب اللي
عم بتصير بالعالم يعني بعطيك مثل بسيط انه
في امريكا
اللي هو الحلم الحلم الامريكي اللي هو
عباره عن واحد يشتغل وكل حياته ويجمعته
يشتري بيت
بيجي هالانسان هذا اللي جمع كل حياته
واشتغل وعرق وجمع اتصال عنده بيت بتيجي
قذيفه الدبابه او قذيفه طائره بتروح لكل
الحلم تبعه وتسوي مشرد بالطريق وبصير طبعا
بنضمن لفئه ال ال الفقراء هذه ما انا ااا
سبب
الاثرياء لو سمحت
سبب الفقر المتوقع ولكن في الوقت الذي
هناك في هناك فقط
على موضوع الاثرياء اليوم في عندك مشروع
يعني الناس اليوم في عندي قسم كبير مثلا
من المخترعين اللي اخترعوا اكتشفوا
المستثمرين اللي غامروا برؤوس اموالهم
اللي حطوا رؤوس الخطر همم
هاي الفتره كانت فتره مثل اي رجل اعمال
بيستفيد من من من الظروف الاقتصاديه
بالعالم
في عندك قسم كمان من الاثرياء اللي اغتنى
بفتره بيسموها اثرياء الحرب للاستفادوا من
الحروب عند قسم كبير يلي عمليه الفساد
الموجوده بادارات الدوله لانه اليوم اسامي
مثل ما عم بسمع بالتقرير انه بدهم يعملوا
مثلا ضريبه مقطوعه 5% مره واحده من ثروات
ال- اا
الاثرياء وبعدين سروي على
ضريبه على الثروه همم هذه نتيجه معكوسه
يعني اليوم انت عمليه التوزيع توزيع همم
الثروات بتصير بين الغني وفي ما بتيجي
بتحطي يدك الغني بتعطيها للحديد
مع منتدى ذابوس الاقتصاد اللي جاء تحت
عنوان التعاون في عالم منقسم اليوم وفي
عالم متجزء بين البشر اليوم كمان احنا
بنعرف ان انا كمان بدي امشي معك بفكره انه
لا يجب ان لو على الاغنياء لانه انا مطفت
مثلا الى الماسك قرر انه يتبرعوا بنص
ثروتهم الى الناس يعني هم يعتبرون من محبي
وفاعليه الخير لكن كيف يمكن اعاده توزيع
الثروات اليوم بين العالم في ظل التفاوت
بين البشر جغرافيه
يعني اول شيء اليوم لا تقدري توزعي توزعي
السروات يعني نحن اليوم نظام اشتراكي بيجي
الواحد بناخذ منحط ايدنا الفقير في
ميكانيكيه في ميكانيزم معايا يا اللي هو
الدولي بتنظم بتنظم عمليه توزيع اذا بدك
السروات بس الدوله قبل كل شيء لازم تضمني
انه الدوله الي عم تقوم بهالشيء تكون دوله
نظيفه ما تكون في فس اداري ضمن الدوله
يعني بصفي بياخذوا الفلوس من الغني
وبيحطوه بجيبتهن ما بيعطوه للشعب العام
الطريقه الوحيده انك انت اليوم
ثروات جديده هي اول شيء بالعلم لانه العلم
لما واحد بيتعلم يعني اذا هون التركيز على
على همم
المؤسسات التعليميه مدارس من جماعات هذه
بتخلي الشعب الانساني
يقدر يعملوا الفلوس ثاني شيء خلق فرص عمل
يعني وهذه فرص عمل مين بيعمل في راس العمل
فرص العمل عندك همم قطاعين بيخلقوا في راس
عمر القطاع الخاص والقطاع العامه القطاع
الخاص اللي هو البرايم حتى القطاع العام
الدولي الدولي اثبتت بكل السنوات بالتاريخ
اللي شفناه انه الدوله هي عباره عن تاجر
فاشله ما فيها تجيء تعمل زائد بصير
باكتريه الدول الخاصه العربيه فاذا القطاع
الخاص هو اللي بيخلق فرس العمل من خلال
انشاء مشاريع جديده بتخلق فرص عمل هون انت
لازم تشجعي الاثرياء تشجع رجال الاعمال
يجوا يستثمروا بها الدول تمنينا الحمايه
تمنينا همم اجواء مواتي للاستثمار لانه هل
الاستثمار لما انا بيجي بيجيب المستثمر
اللي عندي بخليه يستثمر يعني بيخلق فرس
عمل مثلا يعني همم